ich bin Sexualpädagogin und
Sexualtherapeutin in China das ist mein
Job
Leute die einen ausländischen Pass haben
wollen kommen zu mir und ich helfe Ihnen
sich dafür zu bewerben
es gibt definitiv den Trend das junge
Leute in China nach einem anderen
Lebensstil suchen
ich treffe viele Leute mit
unterschiedlichen Erfahrungen und nicht
mag es Ihnen meine Geschichte zu
erzählen und ihre zu hören
wenn es um China geht geht es meistens
um Diktatur Überwachung und null corvit
viele junge Chinesinnen und Chinesen
sehen ihr Land anders oder wollen es
anders wie anders das will ich
rausfinden seit zehn Wochen lebe ich
hier angekommen in einem Land aus dem
viele nur noch weg wollen denn Präsident
hält stur an seiner corona-politik fest
jeden einzelnen Fall jeden Ausbruch will
er mit strengen Maßnahmen im Keim
ersticken
der Flughafen von Peking ist ziemlich
leer Reisen sind ein Risiko es reicht
schon durch ein Viertel gefahren zu sein
wo es einen corona-fall gab und du sitzt
wochenlang irgendwo fest wie sehr Corona
auch unsere Reise bestimmen wird ist uns
hier noch nicht klar
anders als in Deutschland sind solche
drehreisen hier in China immer auch so
ein bisschen Reisen ins Ungewisse es ist
für uns schwierig Leute zu finden die
mit uns sprechen wollen weil viele Angst
haben mit ausländischen Medien zu reden
Angst dass es dann Konsequenzen haben
könnte oft werden auch Interviews ganz
kurzfristig abgesagt weil zum Beispiel
jemand vorher einen Anruf kriegt oder
bei Druck auf die Familie ausgeübt wird
auch Michael befürchtet dass er Probleme
kriegen könnte wenn er uns ein Interview
gibt denn er hilft Menschen die das Land
verlassen wollen und deshalb will er uns
erstmal kennenlernen
Michael lebt in shinjin die Stadt ist
jung und schnell das Durchschnittsalter
in der Hightech Metropole liegt knapp
über 30 der Lebensstil wird shengeance
Speed genannt
die Stadt ist bekannt für ihre
Innovation von hier aus geht neue
Technik in die ganze Welt hier sollen
wir uns anschauen können wie unsere
Zukunft mal aussehen wird
[Musik]
nach dem gemeinsamen Essen ist Michael
einverstanden am nächsten Tag dürfen wir
ihn begleiten Michael ist Geschäftsmann
immer auf der Suche nach neuen Projekten
und Kontakten sein Handy immer in der
Handschuh ich helfe chinesischen
Studenten eine Schule oder Uni im
Ausland zu finden
Leute die einen ausländischen Pass haben
wollen kommen zu mir und ich helfe Ihnen
sich darum zu bewerben
sein Business boomt spätestens seit dem
Lockdown in Shanghai als Millionen
Chinesinnen und Chinesen zwei Monate
lang nicht aus ihren Wohnungen durften
die Suchanfrage nach kanada-auswandern
zum Beispiel Steg im chinesischen Netz
um mehr als 2000 Prozent Michael ist 33
er hat in Kanada studiert und nutzt
seine Kontakte von damals warum so viele
China verlassen wollen da ist der
vorsichtig in seiner Antwort
jeder hat ein anderes Ziel manche
Menschen mögen bestimmte Hochschulen
oder sie mögen das Lebensumfeld in
bestimmten Gegenden also treffen sie
ihre eigene Wahl
viele seiner Kundinnen und Kunden spüren
die Auswirkung der Pandemie und der
strengen Maßnahmen in China denn
Lockdown heißt für viele auch kein Job
kein Einkommen
viele Menschen können kein Geld
verdienen können ihre Bankkredite nicht
zurückzahlen
und haben kein Geld um ihre Kinder zu
unterstützen
Michael will positiv bleiben die
Pandemie als Chance sehen er hat und
pflegt ein großes Netzwerk nennt sie
trifft er regelmäßig auch sie ist
Geschäftsfrau manchmal tauschen Sie
Kontakte aus
Nancy mag den Speed dieser Stadt als
Sexualtherapeutin sieht sie aber auch
Nachteile
wenn Leute hier etwas mit einem Mann
oder einer Frau anfangen dann wollen sie
das schnell schnell
sie wollen keine Zeit damit verschwenden
zu reden sich wirklich zu spüren alles
ist sehr schnell
sie berät Singles und Paare sie will
Geschwindigkeit rausnehmen und dabei
helfen dass Menschen sich näher kommen
in ihrem Büro müssen erstmal die Kinder
raus
dann zeigt sie uns das Sexspielzeug dass
sie auch bei Workshops vorstellt so
offen wie Nancy über Sex und Beziehung
zu sprechen das ist in China Tabu immer
wieder hat sie deshalb Probleme mit der
staatlichen Zensur gerade wurden ihre
Social Media Accounts gesperrt das
vierte Mal in zwei Jahren
wir haben wirklich viele viele Follower
verloren das wirkt sich natürlich auch
auf unser Geschäft aus auf unsere
Einnahmen
außerdem merkt sie dass viele ihrer
Kundinnen und Kunden gerade mehr aufs
Geld schauen müssen denn während der
Pandemie haben viele ihren Job verloren
bei den Jungen ist jeder fünfte
arbeitslos
eigentlich wollten wir noch mit anderen
Leuten in Gendern sprechen doch daraus
wird nichts der
corona-kontrollapparat durchkreuzt mal
wieder unsere Pläne nächste Station
Krankenhaus also ganz sicher bin ich
noch nicht aber ich hoffe dass ich hier
jetzt gerade den Termin von pca-test
gebucht habe den Test den wir gestern am
Flughafen gemacht haben der wird nicht
in unserer App angezeigt weil wir in
ausländischen Pass haben viele der Apps
ohne die in Corona China nichts geht
funktionieren nur mit chinesischem
Ausweis Ausländer sind nicht vorgesehen
und dadurch dass wir immer eine extra
Lösung brauchen ist es auch einfacher zu
kontrollieren was wir machen
im Krankenhaus klappt es aber es kostet
Zeit die wir lieber zum Arbeiten nutzen
würden das ist unser Alltag hier und
mein Team ist froh überhaupt mal wieder
unterwegs zu sein
ich bin ja erst seit ein paar Wochen
hier in China aber für meinen Kameramann
ist es jetzt das erste Mal seit acht
Monaten dass er noch mal aus Peking
rauskommt woher war das wegen Quarantäne
und den Stricken corona-maßnahmen nicht
möglich
am nächsten Tag haben wir unser
Testergebnis es ist negativ und wir
dürfen weiter von der speedmetropole
nach Westen ins Urlaubsparadies Dali
wir sind hier an einem ganz beliebten
fotospot denn Dali ist besonders bekannt
für diesen riesigen See hier hinter mir
viele Chinesinnen und Chinesen kommen
hier zum Urlaub machen und um die Natur
zu genießen und man merkt schon hier ist
gleich so eine ganz andere sehr
entspannte Atmosphäre
Brian und schautie hat die Atmosphäre
hier so gut gefallen dass sie geblieben
sind seit fünf Jahren sind sie hier kein
Vergleich zu der Hektik in Peking wo sie
vorher lange gewohnt haben
[Musik]
als wir hierher kamen spürten wir sofort
hier gibt es nicht diesen großen Druck
alles ist viel entspannter alles
günstiger
in ihrem Haus haben Sie eine Cocktailbar
eröffnet die Kräuter für ihre Mischung
wachsen auf der Dachterrasse inzwischen
zieht es viele aus den Großstädten
hierher
wir haben das gleiche Ziel im Leben zu
chillen das klingt wirklich kitschig
aber irgendwie ist es hier leichter mit
dem Leben klar zu kommen
dass es immer mehr jungen Leuten wichtig
ist ein entspannteres Leben zu haben
in der Generation meiner Eltern war es
so einen guten Job finden arbeiten und
dann in Rente gehen
aber heute wollen immer mehr junge
Chinesen dieses Leben nicht mehr
so liebevoll wie sie ihre Bar führen so
liebevoll kümmern sie sich auch um ihren
alten Hund und genießen es dass hier
alles kleiner ist
hier ist es nicht wie in Peking wenn du
dort jemanden treffen willst musst du 1
2 Wochen vorher einen Termin abmachen
hier siehst du deine Freunde einfach die
ganze Zeit
auch ich merke den Unterschied Dali ist
ein ganz anderes China als das dass ich
bisher in Peking oder shinj
kennengelernt habe
so riesig wie China ist so
unterschiedlich ist auch die Corona
Situation hier im Land hier zum Beispiel
wurden vor kurzem alle Maßnahmen
aufgehoben das heißt wir müssen keinen
Code scannen wenn wir ins Restaurant
gehen die Leute die hier wohnen müssen
keine regelmäßigen Tests machen und man
sieht auch viel weniger Masken im Alltag
besonders für die Stadt hier ist das
wichtig denn die lebt eigentlich vom
Tourismus und dies darauf angewiesen
dass viele Chinesinnen und Chinesen
hierher kommen und hier Urlaub machen
so wie Liu J seit er 15 ist arbeitet er
inzwischen ist der 24 und fährt vor
allem Touristen durch seine Stadt er
liebt es ihn seine Welt zu zeigen ohne
Navi die Straßen hat er im Kopf und er
ist froh hier zu sein
wegen der Pandemie kommen weniger
Touristen und wirtschaftlich läuft es
echt schlecht
viele meiner Freunde mussten in andere
Städte gehen um vorübergehend einen
anderen Job zu finden
als Kind hat er in diesen Straßen
gespielt heute ist die Altstadt ein
Touristenmagnet und Leo Jere findet es
schön dass auch wir diesen Ort mögen
wie alles in Dali spielt sich sein Leben
rund um den See ab und am liebsten
mittendrin er mag keine Großstädte sein
Lieblingsplatz ist hier in seiner Heimat
das Leben hier ist einfach entspannt
ohne viel Druck und das Tempo ist
langsam das finde ich am besten ein
bequemes Leben
3000 Kilometer so weit ist Dali von
Peking entfernt weit weg von der
politischen Führung und ihren Regeln und
auch weit weg von den strengen
corona-regeln der Hauptstadt weil wir
aber dorthin zurück müssen beginnt für
uns mal wieder ein krankenhausmarathon
um ein corona-testergebnis zu bekommen
das ist der verzweifel
te Versuch war leider funktioniert mit
dem ausländischen Pass mal wieder nicht
im digitalstart China brauchen wir als
Ausländer tatsächlich einen auf Papier
ausgedruckten Test wenn ich es richtig
verstanden habe sind das jetzt unsere
bezahlten PCR-Tests und hoffentlich auch
der Termin dass wir den jetzt hier
machen dürfen
nach vielen Stationen
warten
verschiedenen Codes 9 Zetteln stehen wir
dann endlich in der testschlange eine
Stunde haben wir gebraucht mal wieder
Zeit die wir lieber anders genutzt
hätten
am Ende sind wir echt fast dankbar wenn
man endlich diesen Test machen darf
seit ich in China bin hatte ich nie
Angst mich mit Corona infiziert zu haben
aber schon oft Angst irgendwo
festzulegen
dieses Mal nicht wir dürfen zurück nach
Hause zurück nach Peking mit dem Gepäck
die Geschichten der Menschen die uns
einen kleinen Blick in ihr Leben
geschenkt haben Michaels Begeisterung
für die wirtschaftlichen Möglichkeiten
seines Landes und nennt sie es Offenheit
ich habe dies aufatmen nicht mehr der
Hektik der Großstadt hinterher zu hetzen
und liojes strahlen wenn er erzählt dass
das hier für ihn das Paradies ist
ihr Umgang mit den Freiheiten und
Unfreiheiten in diesem Land ist ebenso
verschieden wie ihre Wahrnehmungen der
corona-politik was sie alle eint sie
wollen ihren eigenen Weg gehen